my name is Joshua boo boo I'm miseries
2010 State Geography Bee champion will
be competing in washington DC on may
2015 20 6 this is my house north of cape
girardeau missouri this is Missouri this
is st. Louis then this is Cape Girardeau
the largest city in Southeast Missouri
and the only inland Cape in the world
the name Gerardo comes in the name of a
French trader that established the
trading post a little bit north of the
actual city Louie Laura Muir a french
explorer that was expired for the
spanish founded the actual city of cape
itself in the late 1700s spanish gave
came back to the French than in the
Louisiana Purchase the United States of
arcade for prints since they gave this
gratitude is very large city that's the
two scenes that I showed from the tapes
River wall floodwall a cake on the
Mississippi River that we stopped by
the two scenes that I showed pictures
throughout its history from the 1400s
all the way to 2000s and this is the
Mississippi River Bridge in 1993 the
Mississippi River flooded almost 40 to
50 feet high which is about 20 feet
above the normal about 30 feet
90-93 them the Mississippi River flooded
we've got about 50 feet high which is
about 25 feet higher
in 1861 the battle can chart with the
Civil War took place there were four
forts in cape girardeau at the time one
of which the last one was a standing 14
which I'm showing you right now around
cave you can see monuments and other
statues memorizing the battle it was a
small skirmish not much compared to
Gettysburg maxilla battle this is my
school trinity lutheran school
I go to seventh grade here and about 200
kids go to our school
this is my church st. Andrew Lutheran
Church it's one of five Lutheran
churches in cape girardeau
of one question the National Geographic
asked me to answer is what is being
green means to me and my friends here
well I say that being green is just
being a good steward of what God's given
which is our and all of its resources so
wasting it or causing it to be harmed in
any way isn't being green at all it's
not being a good steward or keeper of
what God's given us however if we
recycle or make good use of our
resources we are being created urgency
mood that's given us wisely so if I was
given a free ticket to travel anywhere
in the world I go to Western Europe you
know the United Kingdom France Italy
Spain Germany Low Countries why because
I visit this all the different landmarks
that they have including the Coliseum
and bro Eiffel Tower in Paris and of
course there's all sorts of different
things in London like the house of
parliament and what's Westminster Abbey
that's why I would go to Western Europe
of the 195 countries in the world I know
about 175 capitals I can identify any
country on the map in almost every
single territory when I tell this to my
classmates there they are completely
blown away and always ask me how do you
do that so one thing I was telling never
ever cram for something don't try to
memorize every let's say capital of
every single state in one night this
spread it out one thing that I learned I
try to learn one new fact every single
day and that normally works very well
and I remember a whole lot more than
trying to cram a whole bunch the night
before a test so one last question they
ask what's a pretty random get true an
obscure geography fact that you've
learned well I have a question to ask
what is in farthest northernmost
settlement in the world the one closest
to the North Pole you know no I do not
well it is alert none of it Canada it is
82 degrees north of the Equator and only
about 100
from the North Pole so they say that
when you wake up on the wrong side of
the bed you have a pretty bad day I
proposed at the right side of the bed is
your Northside north you'll be alert
that day well I hope you enjoyed this
movie and I hope that you look forward
to watching me and 53 other smart
geographers competing the National
Geographic be on May twenty-fifth and 26
in washington DC again I hope you
enjoyed this and goodbye
you